so everybody asks me how I do my snippy
snip and how I'm able to pick up like so
many different flavors well this is how
the market where you can walk in and you
know take a look and like okay yours
okay okay now I've got that down and you
know and then you see many different
things like okay here are baby boomers I
know it's New York City just saw three
bucks and you're like that's disgusting
I can get for a buck you know so you
know cosmos and Gerber daises right so
insane I'm not even kidding right now
Gerber babies have a sense
have the scent that I pick up on a lot
of Alberta yo and so I would never say
that before but now it's in my mind and
luckily I have a solid enough memory
that I'll be able to execute against it
so that's how I do it
my friends you know anytime I'm going
through New York City and I see a
farmers market it's always a good
opportunity to you know smell smell the
round please you know what I mean and so
what you've got to do if you want to
build your snippy snip is take every
advantage of smelling different things
at all times and that is how you build
your